Louise Ignacio Lula de Silva has won the
Brazilian election beating Jaya
baldonaro by a razor thin margin but
what do we know about the man they're
simply called Lula
well Lula was born into poverty actually
he became a shoe shine boy he then moved
into factories before working in in the
Trade union movement and I very much
supported his bids to become present
although he did actually fail three
presidential elections failed to get in
that is he then in 2002 finally won and
he retired in 2011 a series of
corruption allegations were made against
him he did actually go to prison
although the charges and the conviction
was later annulled and now of course he
is the president but he has a very
divided country
nearly half of it hasn't voted for him
well I think it's fair to say that Lula
has an awful lot of issues that he does
have to address for internal consumption
I think it has to be poverty 100 million
people live in poverty 33 million people
or so are thought to be basically on the
verge of starvation so he's promising to
address all of that says he's going to
actually end poverty he's going to
increase housing for people and increase
education make the Health Service better
big problem though is that so far
there's no details about how it's going
to be paid
absolutely none in fact in any detail at
all so that is something though that he
has promised to address and it's of
course it's incredibly popular here with
those who voted for him the other one
which is also popular for those people
here and abroad is saving uh the Amazon
rainforest he's going to change the laws
that bolsonaro has put in place and uh
replace the uh institutions that
boltonaro basically broke down that
support the Amazon but there's a lot of
work to be done there he says though
it's going to start straight away
tomorrow
foreign
[Applause]
leaders all around the world have been
pretty much falling over themselves to
congratulate Lula I think there's a
reason for that I mean a lot of them
know him
um
Barack Obama wants to describe him as
the most popular politician in the world
and I think a lot of them think that he
probably can actually become a sort of
populist that you can do business with I
think also one shouldn't doubt a simple
fact that many of them are quite happy
to see the back of bolsonaro and
actually almost anyone would be better
than him and the way he ran government
here so I think on the international
stage he will be popular obviously the
big thing that people look for amongst
the International Community is the
protection of the environment generally
but obviously the Amazon rainforest
specifically he's already saying that
he's going to change bolsonaro's tactics
of exploitation there and that he
intends to protect uh the uh the forest
and to stop the huge amount of
deforesting that's taking place it's
increased every year that bolsonaro has
been in office that I think is the one
big issue that will make him extremely
popular with the International Community
when Lula retired from office he had 80
percent approval ratings in this country
and for many of the people here he has
almost seen almost like a religious
figure he's hugely popular in in South
America as well so he uh is an amazingly
popular leader among some obviously
there's others who really dislike him I
think the major differences between his
type of government which will be more
ordered and probably a bit more
mild-mannered is that it will be starkly
different to the anarchic chaotic
aggressive and divisive way that
President bolsonaro ran this country it
was actually chaotic on all sorts of
levels and he did his best to break down
an awful lot of the institutions here
the institutions that look after the
rainforest the institutions of Law and
Order as well and so I think the big
change will be is a calming down and
perhaps a more measured response and a
much greater sense trying to represent
all the people of the country not
perhaps just the richest
[Applause]
[Music]